no man like if my own
not just me that ruins my day
[Music]
there's no way i'm gonna enjoy
another
[Music]
hi i'm darius lawson i'm here to answer
questions from the internet uh you can
buy my book everyone is going to die
from all good bookstores and amazon and
then also google my name to find out
is jerking off to nudes of a girl who
has died weird or a nice tribute i feel
like if she's like in in porn then it's
like you're it's no different to
watching patrice o'neill's special
character when produced died i've
watched elephant in the room like twice
in a week so like if the report started
if they're just a girl and like no part
of their life was them being sexy and
you jerked off to them yeah that's not
wrong
that wasn't respectful when she was
alive
there's no way it increases in respect
when they're six feet under yeah
would you rather be able to [ __ ] any
girl you wanted or teleport anywhere in
the world oh
anywhere in the world no customs
um just go home after a gig i'd never
have to stay in a [ __ ] [ __ ] all again
but you could just do a game in spain
and then never live there right
absolutely also if i could tell about
anywhere in the world you you know you
could carry kind of [ __ ] girl you
want because you go
[Applause]
if you had to move it to a different
place on the body where would you put
the vagina
i feel like the vagina is in a pretty
good place maybe maybe like a bit higher
like maybe just at the
at the belly button
just i i don't know man i feel like god
put it in the right place
it's a bit too close to the [ __ ] but
that's not from my life
if you could wipe one group of people
off the earth who would it be i mean i i
mean it's tempting to say in spanish but
i would say the tories any more tourists
um but then i would also anyone who
insists it's pronounced barcelona
again that was me
if you were dating a team but the night
she turned into a hideous creature like
lulu from trip which is still there yeah
yeah because i i don't look my best when
i'm home
i'm very aware that like the daniel's
laws that is on television occasionally
is very different to the dallas laws
that my fiance has to [ __ ]
like she's she's fighting some real
gross versions of me
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out of a bar for oh god i don't
know if i've ever been no i mean i've
been thrown out of disneyland okay but
that works well
oh because i [ __ ] never learned
mickey mouse i caught i used the word
[ __ ] in the cinema there go to disney
florida and we went to see like the like
downtown disney and we're in a cinema
there and there's this really weird
thing that the rest of the world does
like when movies are wrong and that is
the audience shuts the [ __ ] up for the
whole movie and i know that's not
something that exists in america
very american just gives a running
commentary of everything
and there's just this [ __ ] there's
this little kid in front of me i'm about
17 at this time this kid's about 15 and
he's with three girls and he's just
talking the entire time and he's even
annoying all the other americans and i
lean forward and i go shut the [ __ ] up
and it just won't show up and then my
mom tries to shut him up and then he
sort of gives my mama look and i'm a
mummy's boy so once he gets to once he
starts to say something sarcastic to my
mom i lean forward and i grab him by the
back of the neck now he doesn't know i'm
not violent he doesn't know what not in
a fight and scottish to aggressive i
grabbed him by the back of the neck i
went if you are one more word
one more word i'll take you outside and
i'll kick your [ __ ] head in
right and i got like a round of applause
from everyone in the cinema
i suddenly felt like powerful oh my god
like heroes yeah this is great and then
like 10 minutes later nothing starts
talking again everyone's like
the scottish guy
and i lean forward and i go listen here
you [ __ ] come and the second i said
like just everyone moved all their
things will be changed and that was it
that's the one no no word in this
[ __ ] calendar a woman immediately
left and we've got security guards
what if you had to have a theme song
play every time you arrived somewhere
what would it be it's gonna be the
australian steam austin's
like the last year
or
or uh
time to play the game took place
if you had to go to war would you choose
to go during the middle ages the
revolutionary war or world war one no
the revolutionary war is that oh well
yeah yeah yes you guys probably want to
be on that i don't know if you guys are
killing the
[Applause]
what would you trade a three-year-old
day before my baby or someone else's so
if i was babysitting somebody's
three-year-old baby we'll trade it for a
two-year-old baby and then see if
they've noticed
the exact same thing yeah i put them in
the bag
would you rather be a world-class dancer
a world-class singer or a world-class
player i would not like to be a
world-class fighter because i would be
in jail
you think you would use your
to knock someone out i would be in jail
within three days because there's so
many people in the world who need
knocked out and i would appoint myself
as the man who was in charge of knocking
all those cameras
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child who is the greatest
voice of our generation are you kidding
me yeah yeah
without a [ __ ] sick i would
[Applause]
you're not going to go to jail for some
reason but you it's self-defense you
have to survive then we'll be known as
the guy who massacred like
but if i had to use if i could
oh
18 to 28 the 8 to 18 thing is
like i get it but that's nostalgia of
doing it's on those [ __ ] things like
i loved the young with nothing matters
you can do whatever you want and you
know
we used to have fun without drugs and
alcohol and you just play with your
friends for several hours a day and you
know the summer holidays were long are
you sure you're against this yeah that
sounds pretty [ __ ] awesome but that's
that's nostalgic the best years of
my life when i started calmly when i was
17 and i got good at it when i was
20
and then like things started going well
yeah however you were an adult you could
do things you're in charge of your own
life your feelings are your own like
yeah there's way more responsibility but
you can do
so much more that answer is basically
like
did you make it as an adult or not yeah
yeah would you rather live your life as
is or be a billionaire but you have to
blow dudes every day well i do pull it i
have a good life now nobody needs more
like the absolute most amount of money
anyone in the world needs is five moves
like there's beyond that
there's there's nothing else if you
can't be happy with less than 5 million
and also it's the everyday thing like
he's not enjoying that and then that
feels like the only reason i'm a
billionaire blowing him so he's giving
him money
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no way i'm going to enjoy
another
another
choose one drink and never be hungover
drinking never gave weight drinking
always close the deal with chick
and never drinking your tea was a
championship well i'm a chelsea fan it's
what it means
they don't need my help
drinking never gained weight because i
i'm still young enough i don't mind
i'm nervous
like this i've got a real
like it's i know what i did this is
nobody else's fault not my own
and there is something [ __ ] nothing
wrong about being over and also like i
don't i don't have to wake up at night
and go watch like when i'm here
i'm so
it's the only time i'm truly kind to
myself
yeah i think i just
i
[Applause]
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel set reminders with a little
bell comment who you want to see do it
and watch all the other answer the
internets i don't know where anything is
so i'm kind of just moving my hands
around but do all that [ __ ] subscribe
comment reminder watch others you're
welcome don't know why but you're
welcome